we talked about partial sums of the
sequence right so now I want to
introduce some notation talk about what
insights we can gain from think about
this and particularly when we tend to
the AP and GP world because they are so
structured right we can we can use a
unit insights and we have already within
you okay so this this is kind of like
that the cousin if you like of Sigma
notation in that it's talking at exactly
the same thing
it's a some right to partial sum and
what the way I read this is the sum of
the first n terms so this is a little
bit like saying the sum from k okay
take kind of equivalent in my head the
sum of the first n terms okay for that
reason I can actually just write this
out as a pattern right like think back
to our definitions for how long how we
describe a sequence or series so if it's
the first n terms what's the first term
we just call it t1 and then you add the
next term and then the next term and you
keep going right I'm going to write a
little bit on the end here you'll write
the third last term and the second last
term so handle one and then you'll write
the last term the nth term that's s and
the partial sum up to n right so when
you have a look at this new big deal
like that's just a simple idea but we
can take this and we can we can you get
some insights out of it okay so this is
the description based on a pattern right
we already know that you can describe as
a formula there's one other kind of way
to describe a sequence of series right
what was the other way formula or a
recursive definition right
so what would be the recursive
definition of the partial sum of this
sequence hmm well if I want to say what
how do I get to
in the partial sum of a sequence now the
whole idea of recursion is that it's
like if you can work out one then just
give me the next one right work out one
then give me the next one what I want
you in the next one
so the last little term of this nth
partial sum right is going to be TN do
you agree with that I'm just going to
write it over now what is left what is
left
well the answer is all of that is left
right that's everything else that isn't
that last term okay but I already have
language to describe this I've written
it on the board right what is this and
the answer is it's the partial sum mod
2n but up to n minus 1 okay
now you might think well what was the
point of that that's a bit of a trivial
kind of thing right well when we looked
at sequences from the beginning we saw
the recursive definition seems a bit
unusual but actually we can use it for
testing right you remember is this an AP
is it a deep it you can test using the
recursive definition now I'm actually
not quite done yet has anyone noticed
I'm missing something from my recursive
definition this is how to go from one
step to the next I'll give you that
but there's one thing missing what is it
what else does a recursive definition
need yeah some good I need to know where
to start right for instance here is a on
let's go back to a piece it's good I
tell you things I can say here is a
recursive definition for an AP right but
what ap is it what might be an example
that it could be what numbers it is
these could be the even on this could be
the even by a medium but it could be the
odd number suit or it could be like you
know I could start it like a million
bigger a million two which is you know
no particularly important set so not
just how to get from one term to the
next I need the first term I need to
define it so that's the first partial
sum right now ironically I have also
written the first partial sum on the
board right there just kind of hiding
he's here all of this is the partial sum
up to n here in green is the partial sum
up to n minus 1 where is the partial sum
up to what is it that the sum of the
first one terms it's just the first term
right so this one is by definition do
you want at all I need now I have a
recursive definition okay now like I
said this doesn't seem all that useful
but let me show you how you spoke it is
okay what can we use this recursive
definition for would describe this
example in a second but I don't spoil it
say from this line
yeah this line yeah I can generate a
test out of this right that's how we
looked at it with a PS but I can also
turn it around and say if I knew what
the partial summit by the formula for
the partial sum do you see again written
on the board there is also a formula for
any individual term I want do you see it
hiding there just need to rearrange it
ever so slightly there is the info right
any term I want just put in a value of n
so get that guy by himself what I'm
gonna do to both sides I just subtract
this guy right so it's yes do you see
why that makes sense right I guess you
can think about it like this if this is
f sub n right then s of n minus 1 is the
whole green pot so if I take away the
green pot or you get left with is the
nth term okay so for instance suppose I
have a partial sum and I know that it's
40 lot right if you add the first in
terms you'll get in the square right
that sounds like an interesting secrets
I wonder what it is well I can use this
this recursive definition just twist it
a little bit I can use it to work out
what this is and this is actually a very
famous result as you'll see shortly
let's give it a go if this is how I
define
and then TN is the pastor sum up to n
subtract the partial sum up to n minus 1
so that looks like this do you agree
with that there's my partial sum up to n
then a my partial sum up to n minus 1
that is really simple this some simple
algebra here I can do let's expand it ok
what's going to happen with this
negative the in squids are going to
cancel right there's a double negative
from the 2n and then there will be a
minus 1 right this is the nth term all
of a sudden what sequence of numbers is
this what what is the first term N
equals 1 will give me 2 minus 1 it will
give me 1 what's in equals 2 it's 3 I
have the odd numbers here right I have
this sequence tose okay now just think
that did you ever notice this before
did you ever notice that the first the
partial sum here the first of the first
one terms is 1 which is 1 squared the
partial sum of the first two terms is 1
plus 2 which is 4 which is 2 squared the
partial sum here is 9 and then the
partial sum is 16 and 25 now hold on a
second you shouldn't be surprised right
in this recipe because ah what numbers
are awesome right what's this I should
know there should be a nice simple way
to demonstrate this if it comes out to
such a neat thing because I've said
before right why this is a JP quarter JP
because it's geometry hiding in there
which is why our language is like
squared and cubed and so on okay how
could I arrange these
pieces such that when I get enemies
together for example the first five I
should be able to construct them compose
them into a square of side length five
it's not bad
think with me there's only really one
way I cannot represent one geometrically
we mix there there's a one right there's
one dollar
how will I add three dots to this thing
to make a square of side length to this
look how many ways to draw a society a
square so I like to if I put one two
three there's my square of side length
too right
where am I gonna two points right where
am I going to put my five I'm gonna go a
little bit further
there's my square of side length three
and here's my square or side length 4
and sure enough if you add nine to this
guy it looks to me if I can count
anything worth my salt
I've got five square now you see why
this is a famous result
so what's the point
having the formula for the nth partial
sum S sub n okay you can use it to get
out interesting results like this